all right uh I've been the techniques a
little different and it kind of helps
but uh the fall is definitely
challenging as you can see Myas in the
video Tristan when he was little and
Leah who's a very small uh person
lightweight um but they're able to do it
and the the the difficulty
is uh can they keep their Center so that
they don't uh segment into the fall if
they segment into the fall the head is
sure to hit the mat okay that's that's
really the dangerous part but there's
some things that help they're a little
different even in my Desi it's very hard
for them to understand because the
obvious
appearance is more easily graspable and
then EX executable but not really okay
so uh as he comes along uh the first
thing to realize that you're doing is
not moving his arm like
this so you're you're not uh just taking
away the obstacle and he goes up because
then he would do exactly what your Desi
are doing okay this one's a little
different so this one I'm working on
inward spiral so so here I have an
inward spiral this way okay so this
inward spiral is going this way and then
I'm going around it and I'm going to do
another inward spiral so it looks like
I'm going like
this but I'm I'm not which you can tell
by how they fall
okay uh so the first thing is inward
spiral like this IM spiral around it and
here's your other spiral and I do
another inward spiral here so I don't
want to pull in
backwards and I don't want to just push
with two stiff
hands inward spiral two inward spirals
are going like this and I drop my center
and I just keep spiraling dropping my
center and I move my base out of the way
so I can stay with his Center so my
hands are doing this with my center
dropping and then I get out of the way
so I can stay over
him so even if I don't go fast I don't
do the jumping variant I don't have to
kill my
UK inward spiral not just get out of the
way inward spiral spiral turn around it
boom two inward spirals dropping my
Center keep
spiraling
don't push on here just keep spiraling
you'll touch what you touch but you keep
spiraling and I was doing me you're
doing your sheto T it should be the same
only that this is where you would turn
around it here
so you still doing the in spiral shift
away turn around it iner behind him and
then two
spirals two spirals keep
turning
no no no no no turn your inward spiral
don't just pass the arm so go back and
let's watch something okay pull the arm
straight down without the spiral yeah
there you go okay and uh go slow so you
could see what's happening to
him go slow pull it okay so he's kind of
in a straight line and he kind of leans
over just cuz you're pulling his hands
which your pulling his shoulders do you
see that do it one more
time good okay and now do the inward
spiral
instead yes okay and you can turn that
even more so now I want you to turn it
all the way thumb down thumb around
pinky on top cool okay and so he started
the same way but he didn't uh I'm sorry
he started different but he kind of ends
up uh in a similar position okay and
this this time you're going to go around
it as I told you before so thumb and
Pinky rotate go around it good and keep
it
going okay and one more
time same side same
side
okay good all right now something
different happened then let's try it
again on the first one one he was able
to leave his feet where they are on the
second one you got him to
step okay and as a result when you come
up on the first one where he did not
make him
step he was able to stand straight up
when your hand came back up on the
second one where you made him step his
hips were in front of his head and
that's
key there you go okay wait so you see
how his head's behind his hips okay and
now we do the inward the two inward
spirals crunching your stomach
good right and now let's switch
rolls and so the key here is that his
hips get in front of his head to
whatever tiniest degree possible
okay
go
okay and so less degree did his hips
come forward do you see that okay and so
now you're go ahead you're more likely
going to have to pull him backwards to
get the
technique do you see
that okay there's there's more hips
forward which is good and now don't step
back don't do the OB vi just inward
spiral and crunch your
stomach and then just move out of his
way with your foot as he starts to fall
on it push down crunch your stomach
spiral spiral Spiral okay only you you
did the obvious with your hands is you
just push straight down
okay okay so if I leave him where he
is then this technique makes no sense
okay you you should be doing something
else because there's no mechanical
advantage that you need for the
technique you get
it okay so I can't leave him where he is
he's going to move forward you see you
have to get his himself going
forward so he's got to go forward he
can't even though I'm going forward this
circle brings him forward you see that
you see
that don't leave him there there and
then you go
around get his hips
forward and as his hips go
forward don't come all the way back up
because you're going to stand them back
up I want you to picture there's like a
ball here and I'm going to be on the
outermost surface of the ball pressing
down but not so down that his hips can't
go forward you have to feel for that
okay you're coming around so don't go
all the way
off so I go around so that his hips go
forward and then you feel like there's a
downward this you see okay but if I go
too far down and I'll push your hips
back got it and if I come all the way up
you'll be able to stand
up so you're going to
feel this brings his hips forward and
there's the ball do you see do you feel
that okay but I'm still letting your
hips go forward got it so for example
just walk your hips forward and you see
you can do it come back as opposed
to I'm pushing down walk your hips
forward you see I'm locking them do you
get that okay so there is already a
downward this but not enough to stop
your hips from going forward and now
you'll have this angle do you get
it okay and now don't push with your
forearms don't push with your forearms
you just keep turning these you just
keep turning
them and whatever's touching him is
going to push on him but I don't change
the
PO so I make sure that you
move and I'm already pushing on you do
you feel that but not enough to stop you
now I got that tilt this hand comes over
the top I'm grounding on the back foot
and I just
spiral then so he does not fall on me
but more importantly so that I can press
on his main
Mass I have to move to stay up with him
but I'm still going here so there's a
kind of forward do you feel that
forwardness do you see it's going this
way and now to stay with your Moss I
move my
foot this is
[Music]
different and this is
different get his hips moving start to
press down you're already pressing down
you feel it but I don't I keep it so
that you keep moving inward
spiral
okay let's try
it and again same
side okay so here's what the the throw
is counterintuitive and so right now
your arm is keeping them up kind of
press again and your back arm so now for
you to throw him what makes sense is
that you'll just pull him backwards
right go
ahead okay so
uh why inward spirals again remember
this is the embryonic version because I
showed you the dynamic version where
it's really a jumping throw okay but
it's not like
um I'm sorry I can't remember his name
shawa just over here and grabbing okay
that's going to be a young young class
cuz he's going that way okay we are
going to turn his energy so everything
is going to be the same and we're just
going to look at this arm okay so let's
turn this
way and right now my elbow my upper arm
right here is keeping him from going
down the more I push down with my hand
the more I'm just going to make his chin
go forward and so that's why Mak sense
to pull him okay but what tends to
happen when you pull him is they'll turn
out of it he'll turn out of it that's
not it so we'll just do it on one hand
so you can see
move okay and this hand is going to do
an in
spiral it's going to do
this and when it does it the elbow's
going to move you
see we'll do it
again you get there and now you start
inward spiraling crunching your stomach
and now I let his head go out the other
way
okay so my hand actually moves forward
my hands going
forward it's not going backwards to pull
and then the other hand's doing that on
the other side the other hand is doing
it
too so here's that elbow dilemma but no
that's what you want you do want to
touch that you just keep going around
it there is right there just keep going
around it
then you add the second
[Music]
hand boom second hand doing the same
thing so he can't come back to
me he can't
turn you
[Music]
see
okay try it again